if I hired you as a consultant I'm a bad
guy okay and I want to take down World
Trade Center I come I hire you and I say
listen Richard here's a million bucks I
want you to be my project manager you're
gonna be 10 million so I'll give you 10
million bucks tell me how many people we
need okay how long it'll take us to
prepare this to bring the World Trade
Center down you need dozens of
operatives you get access to the core
columns in the beat in in the buildings
it would take months it would take
months interestingly we had a elevator
modernization the largest in in the
world ever going on the nine months
prior to 9 11 who had that contract Ace
elevator who should have had it Otis
Elevator who installed these elevators
and maintained them up until the time
Ace elevator had 85 employees in the
building at the time the the towers were
hit and they fled it was a scandal
documented in USA Today and the they
these are the experts who could help
rescue the firefighters so so that
that's a plausible undercover that's the
point so so the elevator that's been
managing it for a while was what was it
called no not before age okay so Otis
Ace takes it over 85 guys nine months
prior to that that are working on the
elevator perfect so now they let's just
that's not all you had the transfer from
Public Authority the port authority to
private company Larry Silverstein uh
just six weeks prior to 9 11 this deal
went through and he invested only 125
million of his own money leveraged that
to 3.2 billion and bought all the rest
of the buildings he had previously
developed uh building seven but he
placed massive terrorist insurance that
had never been placed on these buildings
uh before and when did he buy the
terrorist insurance
after he secured ownership of of these
this is six buildings just six weeks
prior to 911 okay so now you're talking
this the kind of stuff now gets people
thinking okay so six weeks prior a hunt
guy comes in with 125 million dollars of
his own money he leverages up to three
billion dollars buys terrorist Insurance
you said yeah and he had no reason to
buy these buildings they were half empty
according to many researchers so they
weren't desirable they required 5
billion to 10 billion in upgraded
electrical mechanical and Communications
and they were full of asbestos which
buildings did he buy well he bought the
six buildings uh WTC complex WGC one two
three four five and six that's right he
bought that and other people who enjoy
conspiracies talk about Neil Bush and
the insurance connection but let's set
that aside let me ask you Tom you can't
say that without people not know what
you're saying yeah Neil Bush and the
insurance Kenny chat 20 seconds well
there are people let's say that there
was a massive massive insurance payout
that was here that's one that's
something people are and it goes right
to the 5.68 billion is correct and it
goes to this exactly the point he's
making here that has been perfect so
5.68 billion dollars can you find out
who which insurance companies pay that
do you know who it is or no no not off
him but a Swiss re Swiss repays that
5.68 billion dollars that's a
reinsurance company that's not an
insurance company correct that's the
reinsure they're changing money like mad
in this scheme yeah because no company
is going to take on that much risk right
I mean no that's not what I'm saying
though that's not what I'm saying listen
one of my clients bought a 250 000 owner
insurance policy okay
but he died within the two years in
contestability contestability the
insurance companies spend nearly 25 000
hiring investigators okay they
investigated this thing and realized
that suicide guess what they never paid
out the quarter million dollars
insurance companies don't just pay out
5.68 billion dollars without hiring the
best investigators to prevent them from
paying that money these guys's job is to
hire to prove that nope this doesn't
so like you know accidental insurance is
the most waste of money insurance you'll
ever buy because insurance companies can
always make the argument so to pay for
somebody to pay 5.68 billion dollars was
free
you know you'd have to have that coming
out of another pocket and the 911
Commission even identified
as true the put options uh where
billions not billions Millions were made
um on betting that the the airliners and
other corporations inside the towers
would go down in value dramatically the
next day and they said oh this this is
true but it wasn't insider trading
because it didn't lead to the footsteps
of Osama bin Laden or Al-Qaeda where did
it lead it led right to the Deutsche
Bank Alan Dulles
you I want you to finish your thought
you had a question for you so let's
let's stay at the root of the the tray
that we're on right now so silversteam
buys
the WTC complex
125 million levers it up Not Unusual in
commercial real estate
um but certainly unusual basically on
the size of this and then he goes and
gets the terrorist Insurance do you do
you have that
yeah I have something close to it
the WTC lease holder by terrorism
Insurance just before this is by a fact
Checker just note that up at the top can
you zoom out so I can read it this is
Tyler Joseph's fact check yeah just make
it that's fine make it zoom in a little
bit the other way zoom in a little bit
okay so long-standing urban legend
holder World trust and at least or Larry
Lewis
took out terrorism Insurance just months
before 9 11 attacks okay go a little
lower so we can read the rest World
Trade Center mixture okay so the fact
that they say mixture that by itself by
Snopes and it's a little disturbing okay
Gola lore Gola lore some of the most
persistent contemporary legends about 9
11 attacks involved people supposedly
benefiting foreign event whether it's a
group World Trade Center workers or
fortunately uh called in sick and
escaped certain that's uh that day or
investors who virtually bought put
options on the United American Airlines
stock immediately before the tax thus
profiting when the prices of the stock
fell afterwards American Business
famously signed a 99-year lease on the
World Trade Center complex in June of
2001 to months before it attacks okay
this is disturbing so let me there's the
insurance underwriting remember the
underwriters are called in on the claim
exactly that's the underwriters
underwrite the policy but then the
underwriters with muscle are called in
on the big claims so there it is
Silverstein took out an insurance policy
that for uh uh fortuitously uh
fortuitously cover terrorism not after 9
11 uh Silverstein took the insurance
company to Court Clinton who didn't want
to pay he should be paid double because
there were two attacks he won
laughs
there it is wildest story obviously
contains elements of fact that's also
partly fiction most notably the
implication made via the use of scare
quotes around the world okay that part
you don't have credibility with that one
because that's just a meme that does
well keep going keep going well you have
uh Larry Silverstein's face up there
note that he was on PBS America rebuilds
program uh saying that uh regarding
building Seven's collapse he says well
there's been such terrible loss of life
maybe the smartest thing to do is pull
it
and so they pulled the building and we
watched excuse me and so no they have
that recording multiple people have that
recording off of um all the fire radios
they gave the order and we and and and
the building came down yeah pull it so
he says well I didn't mean to pull the
building I meant pull the firemen out of
the building well guess what the firemen
were told not to go into that building
and fight that fire they were told it
was going to come down on its own so
they they were held back along with news
reporters uh and and People First
Responders like uh uh Kevin McFadden who
says like a train running under my feet
the explosions going on before building
seven came down so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]